Welcome to WrestleTuber 2024!
Huge shoutout to all the members, all the Vtubers coming in here, giving up their day and time participating in this event to wrestle, to give their interviews.
So, really huge shoutout to every participating member.
Each winner of both the show matches and the tournament will receive the WrestleTuber badge!
Gamersup is fully funding and sponsoring this event, and they will be providing and shipping out the WrestleTuber belts to the champions.
But, it feels weird that this seat is empty.
I wonder where is my co-capt...
Oh shit!
Huh?
Seth?
What was that?
Kept you waiting, huh?
This wrestling ring is already haunted by the champion, Doki Bird.
Okay, security?
I thought I said no crashes tonight.
What the fuck was that?
How did they get here?
Hello?
That was your cue!
I don't know how I could have made that any more clear here.
Wait, where do I go?
Little bit...
Ladies, as the first matchup of the day, how are you guys feeling?
I'm really hoping that it's a nice quick match, because, you know, it sucks to hurt people and...
Your name is Limu, alright?
I'm gonna take those limes, alright?
I'm gonna cut them in half, and I'm gonna squirt them on your eyeballs.
And then I'm gonna take another lime, and I'm gonna squirt them on my own eyeballs.
And then I'm gonna eat your ass.
You're gonna eat her ass?
Wait, what?
You're free?
You're gonna eat her ass?
It's been six years.
Sixty-five million years, Gerard.
How have you been doing?
Getting pregnant, I hear.
You've been doing your research.
I see.
The galaxy never disappoints.
You've always been watching me.
I know you have three children who live under a bridge with no mom, no dad, and you eat limes.
That is none of your business!
Keep your nose out of my life!
Are you crying?
I'm not crying.
I'm trying to live.
Gerard, do you have a question for me?
Yes.
Mahogany or oak?
Mahogany.
Okay, good.
That's gonna be the coffin.
I'm gonna put you in six feet under.
Oh, son of a bitch!
Hey, Hakko.
We got some TMI, Justin.
Is this from the bathroom?
What is this?
Yeah, you're like, in the bathroom, Hakko?
Like, what the fuck?
I literally told you, hold up.
I'm taking a shit.
Ping me.
Was it a nervous shit?
Absolutely.
Wait, I thought, like, birds eat eels.
He's a tiny bird.
Okay, to be fair, he is pretty tiny.
My tail is as tall as him.
You have to understand.
Sorry, this is the accurate height.
I'm sorry.
Shinri?
Is that how he sounds?
It's me.
I'm real fine.
Yeah.
Shinri, um, do you think...
You can't understand what you're fucking saying!
That's right.
I know half of the boys out there fucking got slaughtered, bro.
Now, as the sensei, you know, I gotta come out and win for them.
You better, senpai.
I'm rooting for you, buddy!
Hell yeah, baby.
You know, I gotta fucking channel my inner Steve Irwin and fucking tackle you down like a little fucking crocodile.
He fucking died to a stingray!
I just had to poke you in the fronting heart!
Bro, you don't look like a stingray!
Bro, I can just punch you in the heart and you're fucked!
Bring your ass.
You look like the chicken I had at Nando's today.
Wow!
You're just a little robo-boy.
Can't handle all this... kangaroo.
I'm gonna bring my kangaroo.
Yeah?
You're gonna bring a kangaroo?
I will.
I'll bring out two kangaroos.
I'll bring my computer to smack the shit out of you with.
I'll bring... even more computers.
I'm sorry.
You're fighting a leprechaun reject or what's going on here?
Excuse me, that's Fuyo Man?
Fuyo Man smash.
What is this?
Fuyo Man slaps the rap horn.
I'm so fucking dead, you guys.
You're dead already, but you haven't even...
Fuyo Man, Fuyo Man, please, mercy, mercy.
No mercy.
Snuff, you're gonna take that?
Yeah.
What do these cards say?
Just call me Daft Punk, because tonight I'm gonna get lucky.
Hello, hello, how are we?
How are you?
You're about to face someone with a very stinky face.
A stinky diaper.
I will not stoop to this thick and twisted diaper meta.
Today, I fight as a man, not as a baby.
You just say that because you're scared of the diaper.
I don't know how you're gonna win without the diaper, but I'm looking forward to see how this match is gonna go.
I don't know.
I'm not convinced, man.
Okay, everyone who's had a freaking diaper wins, man.
I'm scared.
No diapers for me.
We're going commando today, baby.
That's sad, because when you shit yourself, they're all gonna see.
You know what?
That's fine.
Shit into the air.
That's great.
We shit like men.
Not cowards.
We don't need diapers.
Can't wait for that chocolate fountain, man.
Can't wait.
I see.
Dropper.
Damn!
Wow!
The advantage here keeps changing.
Who's winning?
Bettle or Luto?
I can't tell.
Oh, they keep missing.
They keep jumping and missing.
Ah, there we go.
I wanna see what happens to Luto if she removes her diaper.
It's like those little power limiters, right?
It's like walkways.
It's a power limiter, definitely.
Take out the diaper.
She needs that limiter to fight in a normal man's wrestling match.
Okay.
Oh, the top.
Oh, but Bettle didn't like that.
Oh, headbutt right to the ribs.
Oh, another.
Oh, what's he doing?
Oh, top of the rope.
Oh, I thought he was gonna take it off again.
Come on, do the flip.
You know you wanna.
Max luck.
Oh, fucking broke his ass.
Little, little fuck.
Little squish.
Oh, what is that?
No, the low blow.
Yeah, you're gonna fucking kick me in the balls.
That's illegal.
Yeah, I think again.
The illegal move.
Two, three.
I can't believe it.
With a low blow to win the match.
I didn't think it could get dirtier than the diaper, but here we are.
I, yeah.
My fucking balls.
Listen, to defeat your opponent, you attack the source.
The diaper is the source.
You will go for the heart.
I will avenge Doki.
I will flip on your face and I will beat you to a pulp.
I will take your teeth and remove the venom from them.
It's not necessarily a venomous snake.
I'm one of the types that constrict you.
I'll have you tapping before long.
Let's, uh, let's just say that.
I don't care what your kinks are.
Fight.
Billion seems to be moving at times two speed.
Yeah, I was just about to say that.
She's looking so fucking speedy right now.
Oh, my God.
She got that Final Fantasy haste spell on.
I thought that was me.
Or drugs.
Let's go.
Oh, right in the gut.
Oh, right in the face.
The Rose of Lucera.
How do you block an arm that thick?
Whoops.
Oh, that was close.
Oh.
Whoops.
Whoa.
Oh.
What am I watching?
The wrestling or Olympics?
These flips are fucking insane.
Fillion's in the wrong place.
She should be at the fucking Gymnastic Olympics.
All right.
Not the fucking WWE.
But it's not on me to judge her career path.
One.
Three.
This is it.
That was it.
Fillion.
Fillion won.
Fucking huge.
Against Bulky Bogan.
Holy crap.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
It was a good fun.
Yeah, it was.
The intermission was wild.
Oh, sorry.
We needed a couple extra minutes.
Matyarikun.
You are a Bug.
And what do you have to say about that?
I am a Bug.
And I have a lot to say about that.
I hope she kind of ... I hope she eats my fright.
That's what I hope.
Wow.
Are you technically a ghost spirit?
That's a really great question.
Why are you laughing?
I think Batara is choking.
Batara, how are you going to beat Mint?
First, I'm going to show her my boobs and I'm going to show her my butt.
And then she'll be too embarrassed to fight me anymore.
My personality is shit, so it's all I've got.
I need to know now, Mint, do you like ass and boob?
I'm an ass and a boob.
Ass is life and boob is hometown.
I'm going to motorboat the fuck out of those boobs.
I'm going to get on them nice and juicy and I'm going to...
I'm going to go down in two seconds.
Mint!
It's fine, I'm getting her defenses low.
The bigger they are, the harder they fall, right?
What is she doing?
She's emoting on me.
This is so rude.
She's doing her mom dance on you.
Where did she go?
Oh, and she... Batara got out of the fence and doesn't know that she got the suplex.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
The London Bridge suplex.
Of course I can pull off the London Bridge.
I coined the term.
Of course.
The London Bridge was created for you.
By Mint in the 1980s.
When she was just 70 years old.
And another.
It's in her pin.
Here you go.
One.
Two.
Three.
Yes!
I got everybody!
Mint!
Batara, you talked very lowly about yourself and I think that may have affected your performance.
I know.
I don't think so so much.
I think...
I don't think.
I have a concussion.
Do you recall how many glasses of wine you had before you stepped into the match?
That's a great question.
Thank you for asking.
You know...
This is...
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Batara is having a stroke.
Someone call 911.
Oh my god.
Someone is having a stroke!
Someone's having a stroke!
Oh god.
I...
I'm scared.
Why are you scared?
I...
I've seen that thing in the ring.
That's...
It's not human.
...
It's just chill.
Let's just chill.
Listen.
I made a promise.
Made a promise.
I beat the diaper meta.
The diaper meta's going down.
Or I die in the ring.
The flip jump and the fucking...
Oh my God!
Is this just Tekken?
He plays one Tekken, and is now an expert.
Yeah.
What is in Fuyo Man's pants?
I mean... you know what's in his pants.
On the back side?
Oh, the back side!
You think I meant...
You also know what's in his pants.
I'm being told that it's a coin.
I hope it's not a chocolate coin.
Fiddle, knock him out so he can go inside!
Oh my god.
Fiddle slid in like a ferret.
Is Fuyo Man at...
No!
Fuyo Man got him DQ'd!
Fiddle wins!
Oh my god!
Fiddle eliminated both diaper players!
Fuyo Man, what happened?
Fuyo Man BP.
You know what I'm more surprised by?
The fact that Fillion made it this far.
But she looks like she has no muscle in those bones.
Fillion, are you just gonna take that?
I know, I know.
But here's the thing.
You know who's built like me?
Luffy.
And he's going to be king of the pirates.
That's true.
I'm literally carrying your legacy right now.
Oh shit, you're right.
Sorry, sorry.
Fillion, kick her ass.
Hey, hey, wait a second!
Look at how malnourished she is.
Did anyone feed her?
Did anyone feed Fillion at all?
Is she yellow from being a Simpsons?
Or is she yellow from her scurvy?
I feel like we've kept Fillion in a cage since this was announced.
The crowd's cheering her on.
And she hits those!
See?
Oh.
Wait.
You teleported!
Oh my god!
You teleported to Fillion!
That was a big personal kid.
You really did.
You're gonna lose after teleporting!
Oh no!
One!
Two!
Stop!
I don't
believe you lost after teleporting!
You know what?
At least I beat Matara.
That's all that matters.
Mint, you were a worthy opponent.
One of the toughest I've ever faced.
I have a spot on my crew just for you.
On the right hand of my ship.
Leading my steering wheel.
What?
She can't drive though.
Yes I can!
Shut up!
This match?
It's not just the finals.
This is personal.
What did Fillion do to you?
Why?
Fillion called me Charlie!
Oh, you're still mad about that?
Yeah, I'm still mad about it!
You all did this to me.
I'm gonna take my fist and put it through your trolley face.
You understand me?
Oh my god.
She pulled out the Charlie.
She called you by your fake name.
Well, then I'll call you David.
David?
My name's not David!
David!
Seems like Battle is currently winning the polls, Fillion.
Wait, how?
Battle's like a knock-off version of me though.
Is he not?
What?
What the?
Do you do the ball grabs though?
I fight with honor.
And I fight for my friends.
What friends?
Listen up, Charlie.
Your name?
Is Beta.
Your drip?
And your favorite video game?
Is for Betas!
How did you know I liked League of Legends?
Oh my god.
She's beyond saving.
Ladies and gentlemen.
It speaks for itself.
Like every match he got through, he was not confident at all.
Yeah, exactly.
It was like that... being pushed into...
What?
Oh, that is...
One...
Two...
Okay.
It's a match.
And there was...
Oh, Finn.
What's going on?
Oh my god.
He's getting spanked like a bad child.
Bad baby.
It was like a fake of this... of the whole tournament.
Oh yeah.
I think so.
Wait.
I'm better.
One.
Two.
Oh that was so close.
That was so close.
I thought it was over.
I was ready to call it.
Oh my god.
I felt like the ref might have been paid off.
That should have been three.
I counted in my head and it was three.
Hey, what are you saying, Doki?
Are you saying this is not a fair, you know...
Well, I'm not saying it.
I'm implying it.
Is this your tournament?
Yes.
She sees me.
Here we go!
One!
Two!
Oh!
What?
Elaine gets trolled.
Oh!
Where'd the lights go?
This is so weird!
Oh my god!
She copied the moves!
It doesn't matter!
She knew what to do!
She knew what to do after me!
Yeah, she downloaded your moveset and knew how to counter it.
Oh my god!
Vale is maxing that luck right now!
That did not look good for Fillian.
That looks like it's definitely her.
Oh, her legs.
She ain't flipping anytime soon anymore.
I don't think so.
He's getting rid of all her appendages so she'll never flip again.
It's because she doesn't get enough calcium.
Her bones are brittle.
Someone throw her an orange.
He's not done playing around with her.
Oh!
And another one.
Oh, here we go!
Whoa!
One, two, three!
Your winner for WrestleTuber 2024!
The Charlie Denier!
The Diaper Destroyer!
The Baby Girl himself!
Valor!
That was the most insane match I've seen today, Mint.
Absolutely.
It was worthy of the finale.
How do you feel being such a winner and holding that championship belt?
You know, it feels good.
It feels good.
I had some brothers in this and this.
I had to kill my brother to get here.
So I had to absorb his nutrients to become more powerful.
Vettel here will be holding on to that champion belt to represent the winner of the very first WrestleTuber 2024.
No one will stop him.
Unless...
We now have a new contender?
Who are you, sir?
I'm Heavyro.
I don't have to fight him, do I?
Oh, you're fighting this 3D man right now.
I'mma make that, I'mma make that heavyro.
It's not over, Vettel.
You gotta defend your title.
Already?
Are you ready?
Where is my bell?
It's over there, sir.
It's over there.
No, no, no.
Please don't hurt us.
All right, battle.
Good luck.
Good luck, battle.
Off to the ring we go.
Good luck, everybody.
I don't know.
Battle looks pretty puny next to that guy right now.
That one got me.
Oh, shit.
You're...
Oh, my God.
This is definitely the wrong way, class.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
This just falls to the ground.
It's okay, battle.
You can do it.
Just get up, battle.
Get up, battle.
You got this.
Oh, my God.
The arms are limp.
What the fuck?
Battle, please.
It's a fucking double flip into battle.
Guys, I...
Guys, I think I feel a little bit bad.
He's tired.
He, like, totally let his guard down thinking he was tired.
He was done with all these matches.
Yeah, like, he unclenched, you know?
Yeah.
He was fully clenched up during the entire tournament, and he thought...
Battle thought it was just over.
Yeah.
Wait.
Is it...
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh!
What in the flip?
Oh, no.
He's just...
He's just emoting into the ring.
Oh, God.
No way.
Oh, my God.
Are we done?
All of five minutes.
But we, um, yeah.
We have a new champion!
Yuuman.
Did I win?
Yeah.
No.
He had the title for 14 seconds.
How did it feel to be a winner for five minutes, Battle.
Well, it felt great.
It felt great.
I'm, you know, I'm happy to be a winner of something for about 5 minutes, but...
I just lost it already...
So proud of you, man.
Pretty proud of you.
A real chad.
Violence.
U MAN, U MAN, U MAN, U MAN, U MAN, U MAN
U MAN, U MAN, What are your words to your fans!
To your audience!
Um...
Check my music video.
Is this a self-promo?
Wow.